nämlich mit rainer sobottka aus duisburg
mit dem wir zugeschaltet sind schönen
guten abend herr sobottka würden sie
sich als ja unionswähler als vielleicht
sogar stammwähler bezeichnet
guten abend herr sparen in guten abend
erweisen nach berlin also ja ich würde
mich und stammwähler auf bundesebene
bezeichnen ich bin jetzt 61 jahre alt
und habe meine ersten erfahrungen
1979 mit einer veranstaltung in herne
mit franz josef strauß gemacht und war
dann nach auch immer mit der cdu
verbunden bei allen wahlen die dort
stattfanden und ich werde in diesem jahr
wie so viele andere meiner bekannten
freunde oder auch andere bürger die man
auf der straße reden hat nicht mehr die
cdu wählen und der grund liegt einfach
darin dass wir mit der führungsperson
armin laschet nicht zurecht kommen und
ich spreche nicht nur für mich sondern
ich spreche wenn ich aktuelle umfragen
sehr für dreieinhalb ist vier millionen
wähler wie bisher die cdu wählen würden
aber das jetzt nicht mehr machen weil
sie einfach mit der führungsperson von
armin laschet nicht übereinstimmen das
heim das ist auch für mich suchen das
heißt also bot gar mit einem wechsel des
pferdes sage ich mal also wenn jetzt
doch noch markus söder zum zug käme dann
wäre ihre stimme wieder mit an bord für
die union
definitiv nicht nur meine und wie
ersparen das eben mit dem verkäufer
sprach wenn ich etwas kaufe da muss ich
vertrauen zu einem verkäufer haben unter
einer stadt in den letzten monaten
obwohl er ein sehr guter politiker ist
aber für diese ganzen herausforderungen
die zur zeit anstehen hat er nicht mehr
das vertrauen in der bevölkerung und aus
dem grunde ist es so dass da nicht nur
strategie oder taktik wechsel habe ich
mir gerade aufgeschrieben was sie sparen
sagte notwendig ist sondern einfach wie
es auch im sport möglich ist eine
auswechslung ersparnisse in die stimme
von herrn sobottka wurscht im gegenteil
ich werbe und pferde bis zum 26
september um die stimme von herrn
sobotka werden
und um vertrauen werben und sie wird
nicht richtig verstanden sind sie aus
duisburg sind wir beide
nordrhein-westfalen
sobotka list ich denke sie spüren doch
auch und sind auch in nordrhein
westfalen den unterschied den armin
laschet gemacht hat und macht seit 2017
wer dieses große bundesland regiert er
kennt ja armin laschet als landesfarben
offenbar hat das bisher ihn nicht dazu
bewogen das kreuzchen abzusehen dort bei
der union zu machen bei dieser wahl
das ist richtig bis zu dem zeitpunkt
seitdem in den letzten zwei bis drei
jahren mit kubik 19 mit dem klimawandel
mit dem auftreten von herrn laschet
jetzt wolf verschiedenen veranstaltungen
einfach sich herausstellt dass herr
laschet im moment nicht mehr der
richtige mann am richtigen ort für diese
probleme da sind weil markus söder
einfach ein entschlossener mensch ist
wirkt sich klar abgrenzt der klar
veränderungen möchte die auch
kommuniziert und das wünschen sich die
bürger zur zeit und aus dem ritter
laschet diese stimmen nicht mehr
bekommen ich kann nur plädieren in lyck
nicht auszuwechseln weil die politik
entfernt sich immer mehr von den bürgern
und von den menschen das wären drei
jahre alt und stammt weder sagen 'bitte
wechsel dann tut es doch